[Musik]
die Türkei vor der Präsidentschaftswahl
kann Langzeit Herrscher Erdogan wieder
gewinnen
erdogan ist für uns glauben Sie mir wie
Atatürk Erd sehr vieles gemacht für die
Türkei noch immer leidet das Land unter
den Folgen der Erdbebenkatastrophe mehr
als 50.000 Menschen sind gestorben der
Staat hat versagt
es kam keine Hilfe offen gesagt viele
sind durch Kälte und Hunger unter den
Trümmern gestorben
dazu hat eine Wirtschaftskrise das Land
im Griff Lebensmittel für viele kaum
noch erschwinglich
ich muss überall hinlaufen und
vergleichen alles ist furchtbar teuer
geworden
beobachte sprechen von einer der
wichtigsten Wahlen in der Geschichte des
Landes
gewinnt in der Türkei die Demokratie
oder wird das autoritäre System
verstärkt diese Frage ist entscheidend
ich bin durch die Türkei gereist auf der
Suche nach der Stimmungslage im Land
kurz vor dieser richtungsweisenden Wahl
unterwegs im türkischen Erdbebengebiet
in den Städten noch immer Bilder der
Zerstörung auf fast drei Monate nach dem
Beben sind die Spuren der Katastrophe
deutlich sichtbar
an der Straße lange Schlangen für
Finanzhilfen vom Staat
statt mit Wiederaufbau sind sie hier
noch immer mit Abriss beschäftigt
in der zerstörten Stadt passarchik will
ich herausfinden wie das Leben der
Menschen nach der Katastrophe weitergeht
weil viele Restaurants eingestürzt sind
kochen Sie jetzt dann Ständen unter
freiem Himmel
auch von dieser belebten Einkaufsstraße
ist nicht viel übrig geblieben
einen Nachbar und ein Berufskollege von
mir daneben war eine Tierarztpraxis
außerdem gab es noch einen Handyladen da
drüben an der Ecke war eine
fladenbrotbäckerei
sein Juweliergeschäft hat Mehmet
gündischli erst seit wenigen Wochen
wieder geöffnet er und seine Familie
haben noch Glück gehabt für Wohnhaus und
der Laden haben dem erdbebenstand
gehalten doch der Neuanfang fällt schwer
fast all ihre Freunde und Bekannten
haben die Stadt verlassen wer ist denn
das Leben hier jetzt für all die die
überlebt haben
wir können den ganzen Tag weinen wir
vermissen unsere Freunde die Geschäfte
die Belebtheit die sozialen Kontakte
hier in diesem Geschäftsviertel gibt es
nur noch mich und an der Ecke drüben ein
weiteres Geschäft das wieder geöffnet
hat wir machen weiter aber wir sind sehr
betroffen
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl 2018 haben
hier drei von vier Erdogan gewählt jetzt
nach dem Beben könnte sich das ändern
zumindest vorsichtige Kritik
was glauben Sie denn wie wird sich diese
Erdbebenkatastrophe auf die Wahl
auswirken
die Hilfe nach dem Beben kam etwas spät
und sie war unzureichend
es waren zwar auch viele Regionen
gleichzeitig betroffen aber so kann man
nur fünf oder sechs Rettungsteams und
das war nicht genug
noch größer ist der Frust hier wenige
hundert Meter weiter seit Monaten leben
die die alles verloren haben in einer
Zeltstadt mit dem Nötigsten werden sie
versorgt doch es ist mir existieren es
wirklich leben
wir werden hier behandelt als ob wir
Bettler wären wenn wir nach etwas Fragen
bekommen wir immer wieder unfreundliche
erniedrigende antworten
sie sagen dass wir es ja im Geschäft
selbst kaufen können
aber wofür sind die Hilfsgüter da wenn
Sie uns nicht gegeben werden
nur reif führt uns durch das Lager sie
sagt eigentlich sollten die Menschen
hier längst den Container umgesiedelt
werden zumindest ein Stück Normalität
zurückbekommen doch bisher sei das nicht
in Sicht seit dem Erdbeben ist nur reif
von ihrem Staat enttäuscht
es kam keine Hilfe offen gesagt viele
sind durch Kälte und Hunger unter den
Trümmern gestorben
niemand hat sie herausgeholt
wir haben ein Horrorfilm durchlebt
wie viele Leute leben hier
erzählt mir nurai sie ihr Mann und die
beiden Söhne wenn es regnet stehe der
Boden unter Wasser ihre Entscheidung
steht fest bei den Wahlen will sie für
die Opposition stimmen
es gibt ja viel Unmut wegen der
verspäteten Hilfe der Regierung wird es
auch für die Wahl entscheidend sein
wenn diese Ignoranten nicht sehen wollen
und seit so vielen Jahren immer Erdogan
die Stimme geben dann können wir keinen
Fortschritt erzielen es gibt hier keine
Fortschritt es gibt niemanden etwas
aufbaut
die Erdbebenkatastrophe könnte Präsident
Erdogan bei der Wahl entscheidende
Stimmen kosten weil es der sich im
Wahlkampf feiern doch seit Monaten steht
er wegen der späten und unzureichenden
Erdbebenhilfe vor allem in den Kurden
Gebieten in der Kritik um Boden gut zu
machen gibt der vollmundige Versprechen
unser Ziel ist es den größten Teil der
Häuser für die Erdbebenopfer innerhalb
eines Jahres fertig zu stellen
wie schnell der Wiederaufbau wirklich
vorangeht davon will ich mir selbst ein
Bild machen hier im Ort nur da entstehen
im Rekordtempo neue Häuser der
Ortsvorsteher hat keine Zweifel am
versprechen seines Präsidenten
natürlich finden wir es realistisch wenn
der Staatspräsident ist versprochen hat
dann gibt es kein Problem er ist ein
guter Staatspräsident er hilft jedem er
schafft das
der Haken ist hier werden nur 14 Häuser
gebaut eigentlich bräuchte das Dorf aber
50 die neuen Häuser sollen nach Schwere
der Schäden verteilt werden im Zweifel
entscheidet das Los
[Musik]
es wäre gerechter wenn sie so viele
Häuser bauen wie es im Dorf gibt und die
an alle verteilen würden
dann geraten die Menschen auch nicht
aneinander so wird es Streit geben
ihre Schwester verloren sie erfuhr unter
den Trümmern
ihr eigenes Haus steht zwar noch aber
rein traut sie sich bis heute nicht aus
Angst vor Nachbeben die Frage ob Sie ein
neues Haus bekommt ist für sie
wahlentscheidend
wir sind deine ganze Familie meine
Mutter mein Vater wir sind alle Erdogan
Anhänger aber wenn es so läuft dann
werden auch wir die Seite wechseln wenn
die Häuser nicht gerecht verteilt werden
für den Wiederaufbau hat Erdogan viel
versprochen selbst seine treuesten
Anhänger haben Zweifel ob er das auch
einhalten kann
ich bin in der Hafenstadt ist kenderon
in der Provinz Hatay auch diese Region
hat das Beben besonders schwer getroffen
tausende haben ihr Zuhause verloren und
müssen auch hier immer noch ins Zelten
ausharren
so wie hat die Galli
wie ist ihre Situation hier
unser Zustand im Zelt ist schwierig vor
allem wenn es regnet und windig ist
unsere Zelte fliegen weg wegen der
Lautstärke können wir nicht schlafen an
den Rändern gibt es Ungeziefer zwar
haben sie unsere Zelte mit Mittel
dagegen besprüht aber wir schlafen mit
Angst wenn es einen Container geben
würde wäre es bequemer es wäre
gesünderli zeigt mir auf wie wenig Raum
sie mit ihrer Familie lebt
stehen kann man nur in der Mitte des
Zeltes
in einem Zelt zu leben ist schwer wir
sind drei Personen ich mein behinderter
Mann und mein Enkel hier auf dem Boden
schlafen wir zu dritt
in der Zeltstadt hat sich
wahlkampfbesuch angekündigt
Susan Sahin Abgeordnete der größten
Oppositionspartei CHP ist zu Gast mit
einer Wut Rede im Parlament gegen das
miese erdbebenmanagement der Regierung
ist sie in der Türkei berühmt geworden
sie hofft dass die Katastrophe in ihre
Folgen Erdogan Stimme Kosten werden
die Menschen haben nun wahrgenommen dass
diese Regierung nach dem Erdbeben keine
geeigneten Maßnahmen ergriffen hat das
wird dieses Mal zu einem Wechsel führen
das Erdbeben als Abstimmung auch über
das Krisenmanagement Erdogans
tatsächlich aber sagt Susan Sahin geht
es bei der Wahl um viel mehr ist es
letztendlich auch eine Wahl zwischen
Demokratie und Autokratie
natürlich geht es bei diesen Wahlen auch
um unsere Demokratie zwar steht auf dem
Papier dass wir in einem demokratischen
Land leben in Wirklichkeit haben wir uns
aber sehr von der Demokratie entfernt
wir sind zu einem Land geworden das vom
Wort eines Mannes regiert wird das passt
nicht zu unserer Natur
seit 20 Jahren regiert Präsident Erdogan
jetzt die Türkei an die Macht gekommen
mit dem Versprechen von mir Demokratie
der Achtung von Menschenrechten und
einer Orientierung nach Westen
doch je länger seine Amtszeit dauert
desto autoritärer sein Regierungsstil
gewaltsame Niederschlagung der
gysi-proteste 2013
Massenverhaftungen nach dem
Putschversuch 2016
Einrichtung eines präsidialsystems 2017
die Türkei als ein Mann starb
[Musik]
er will Schluss damit machen
Oppositionsführer Kemal kilistarolu gilt
als Anti Erdogan ein Bürokrat wenig
charismatisch Spitzname Büro Klammer
doch mit seiner verlässlichen Art ist es
ihm gelungen ein ungleiches sechs
Parteienbündnis zu schmieden dem gehören
neben seiner Mitte Linkspartei CRP auch
konservative und sogar nationalistische
Parteien an das gemeinsame Ziel Erdogan
stürzen und sein Präsidialsystem wieder
abschaffen
als Vorsitzende der politischen Partei
die die nationaler Allianz bilden haben
wir uns auf einen Fahrplan für den
Übergang zu einem gestärkten
parlamentarischen System geeinigt
[Musik]
doch ob es wirklich dazu kommt darüber
wird neben dem Erdbeben auch das zweite
große Wahlkampfthema entscheiden die
Wirtschaftskrise
ich bin unterwegs in Istanbul dem
wirtschaftlichen Zentrum der Türkei
[Musik]
auf dem berühmten ägyptischen Basar will
ich wissen wie sehr den Händlern die
Krise zu schaffen macht
danke darf ich probieren
er kann Aktas ist am Bodensee
aufgewachsen in seinem Laden verkaufte
Tee und Gewürze wegen der hohen
Inflation musste auch eher seine Preise
anpassen hier bei den Preisen für die
Lebensmittel wie ist das so sehr hoch
gestiegen früher zum Beispiel
Chili habe ich das früher für 400 Lehrer
verkauft jetzt verkauft es für 1000 100
Lehrern
aber sie verdienen nicht das Dreifache
nein wir haben früher viel besser
verdient als jetzt
weil er viel an zahlungskräftige
Touristen verkauft trifft in die
Wirtschaftskrise nicht so hart wie viele
andere Türken und so ist seine
Bewunderung für Erdogan ungebrochen
erdogan ist für uns glauben Sie mir wie
Atatürk er hat sehr vieles gemacht für
die Türkei glauben mir die Preise sind
hoch alles hoch aber wir lieben ihn aber
er hat was gemacht gegen für die Türkei
in den ersten zehn Jahren erdogan hat
die Türkei gebt die Wirtschaftsleistung
pro Kopf stieg auf fast das Dreifache in
den vergangenen zehn Jahren dagegen
Stillstand auch wegen Erdogans
fragwürdiger Niedrigzinspolitik stieg
die Inflation im Herbst auf bis zu 85
Prozent
ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung lebt
unter der Armutsgrenze beim junge Türken
denken ans Auswandern gerade
Lebensmittel können sich viele Menschen
kaum noch leisten
bei Allah ja die Preise muss ich mir 100
mal anschauen ich muss überall hinlaufen
und vergleichen alles ist furchtbar
teuer geworden
ich hoffe die Menschen können zwischen
richtig und falsch unterscheiden und bei
der Wahl die richtige Entscheidung
treffen es ist klar dass das so nicht
weitergeht
[Musik]
Staatspräsident Demirel hat früher mal
gesagt leere Töpfe können jede Regierung
wegfegen
bin im Istanbuler Stadtteil Kasim Pasha
Erdogan Kernland hier im islamisch
konservativ geprägten Arbeiterviertel
ist der spätere Präsident aufgewachsen
die Wirtschaftskrise ist auch hier
deutlich sichtbar lange Schlangen am
staatlich unterstützten Brot verkauft
hier kostet das Brot nur die Hälfte und
trotzdem halten viele Erdogan die Treue
ich bin auch von der Krise betroffen
jeder andere Staatsbürger aber das ist
nicht nur in unserem Land so die
Teuerung betrifft die ganze Welt
ich hoffe dass diese Regierung an der
Macht bleibt
es gibt keine bessere Regierung
dass die Menschen trotz Wirtschaftskrise
in Armut weiter auf Erdogan setzen sorgt
beim Betreiber des Brot Verkaufs für
Verwunderung
ich will es einfach nicht verstehen wenn
alles gut und die Wirtschaft angeblich
so gesund ist warum stellen sich die
Menschen in eine Warteschlange um ein
volksbrot für drei Lira zu kaufen
wie viel Sprengkraft in der Diskussion
um die Wirtschaft steckt erlebe ich kurz
danach ein Mann mischt sich ein als ich
mit einem Erdogan Anhänger spreche
was ist schon dabei wenn du mal eine
Sache nicht kaufen kannst dann lass es
halt
sprechen sie nicht zur einseitig sagen
sie die Wahrheit hast du erzählt dass du
von der Rente lebst
ich komme damit zurecht
falls du Mieter nein ich habe zwei
Wohnungen weißt du wie viel die Mieten
kosten dann zahl eben keine Miete
hättest du doch eine Wohnung gekauft
sondern investieren sollen wir so
weitermachen
das ist ein Oppositioneller die Miete
kostet mich fast die ganze Rente
ihre Gegner ruhig zu stellen hat die
Regierung zuletzt fleißig
wahlkampfgeschenke verteilt den
Mindestlohn die Rente und die Gehälter
von Staatsbediensteten angehoben
Geschenke verteilen Sie auch hier an
diesem Wahlkampfstand der
Regierungspartei AKP Beutel mit
Werbematerial ich will wissen was sie
hier zur Wirtschaftskrise sagen
die Wirtschaft wird viel besser werden
das braucht aber Zeit wenn in der Türkei
produziert wird dann wird sich die
Wirtschaft verbessern
die Wirtschaftskrise ist Problem dass
sich von allein lösen wird das Erdogan
wiedergewählt wird davon gehen Sie hier
fest aus
nur hat wieder gewinnt
er wird mit 60 Prozent gewinnen wegen
der Dinge die er geschaffen hat Straßen
Tunnel hier gibt es zwei Tunnel die
unter dem Meer durchführen das wurde mit
sehr großen Herstellungskosten gebaut
aktuelle Umfragen sprechen eine andere
Sprache
demnach liegt das Oppositionsbündnis in
der Gunst der Türken vor der Regierung
Erdogan
beobachter gehen von einem Kopf an Kopf
Rennen aus
ich bin bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung
der Oppositionspartei CHP im Falle eines
Wahlsiegs soll der Istanbuler
bürgermeisterpräsident werden mehr als
4000 Menschen haben sie hier im Ramadan
im April zum gemeinsamen Fastenbrechen
eingeladen inklusive Gebet
[Musik]
gilt als einer der Hoffnungsträger der
Opposition die Regierung Erdogan will
ihn mit einem Politikverbot belegen mit
uns sprechen will er an diesem Abend
nicht betont stattdessen noch einmal die
große Erdbebenhilfe seiner Stadt
Istanbul
mit unseren 86 Millionen Menschen in der
Türkei werden wir alles tun um die
Schmerzen der Betroffenen zu lindern
werden wir große Entbehrungen auf uns
nehmen
auf einen Wandel im Land
mit einem möglichen Wahlsieg verbinden
sie große Erwartungen
[Musik]
wir würden endlich wieder frei atmen
können wir könnten uns wieder frei
äußern darauf verzichtet im Moment jeder
weil einem sonst etwas passieren kann
warum gibt es die Politik überhaupt
damit die Menschen miteinander
Kompromisse eingehen können aber leider
gibt es das im Moment nicht mehr
kann die Opposition diesmal wirklich
gewinnen
zurück im Stadtzentrum von Istanbul
in einem Café treffe ich den
Politikwissenschaftler Suat ist jelly
Bee er hat schon für verschiedene
Parteien Wahlkampagnen geleitet
wie wir werden sie denn den
Oppositionsführer kille ich da Rollo
bisher war ja eher immer Platz hat er
trotzdem eine Chance gegen Erdogan
das türkische Volk liebt solche
zurückhaltenden Führungspersonen normal
nicht besonders
allerdings haben die Sprache und die
Ausdrucksweise von Erdogan das Volk bei
manchen Themen sehr polarisiert und
ermüdet so dass die Chancen von Kilic
derolo gestiegen sind
vor meiner Reise haben wir die ZDF heute
Youtube Community gefragt was sie über
die Wahl wissen will
wenn Erdogan verliert was passiert dann
würde die Niederlage eingestehen wird er
wegen Korruption angeklagt
der Präsident würde die Niederlage
eingestehen danach würde sicherlich ein
Verfahren beginnen und man würde prüfen
ob es zu klagen und
Gerichtsverhandlungen kommt
das wird sicher der Fall sein doch damit
eine Verurteilung stattfinden kann muss
im Parlament eine gewichtige Mehrheit
dafür vorhanden sein
meine Reise führt weiter in das
politische Herz der Türkei in die
Hauptstadt Ankara
wir fahren vorbei am Parlament und am
scheinbar endlosen Komplex von Erdogans
Präsidentenpalast
mehr als aus dem Auto Filmen ist an
beiden Orten nicht drin sonst ist sofort
die Polizei zur Stelle
in Ankara bin ich mit der prokurdischen
HDP verabredet sie könnte bei der Wahl
den entscheidenden Unterschied machen
die HDP selbst gehört nicht zum großen
Oppositionsbündnis unterstützt es aber
indirekt indem sie auf einen eigenen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten verzichtet
Hauptsache Erdogan schlagen sagt
Parteichef Mieter Sancha der lange in
Deutschland gelebt hat wie wichtig ist
die kommende Wahl für die Türkei
sehr wichtig ist
also eine der wichtigsten Wahlen in der
Geschichte der Türkei kann ich sagen
entweder diese Linie das Autoritarismus
in allen Bereichen des Lebens wird sich
etablieren oder wir werden noch eine
Möglichkeit für einen neuen Aufgang
ermöglicht gegen sanjas Partei läuft ein
Verbotsverfahren wegen angeblicher
Kontakte zur Terrororganisation PKK die
HDP fürchtet sogar ein parteivverbot
kurz vor der Wahl
[Musik]
Sascha geht fest davon aus dass Erdogan
versuchen wird die Wahl zu manipulieren
wichtig sei deswegen ein deutlicher Sieg
seines Gegenspielers Kilis Derulo
Hauptsache
sechs sieben Prozent
Unterschied
lich
so nicht mehr machen oder manipulieren
das ist nicht möglich ich habe auch eine
Frage aus der Community mitgebracht und
die lautet was glauben sie wird Kemal
gelichterolu für die Kurden tun hier ist
ja richtig das
gewordenen
sich entscheiden wird oder den Willen
zeigen wir das die Kundenfrage nicht mit
Repression mit
militärischen Mitteln
die Methode ist sehr sehr wichtig und
wenn er sich für eine friedliche Lösung
einsetzt ist das ein Gut wird es ein
guter Ansatz sein die zweite Frage war
wie wird die Opposition die Türkei
verändern wenn sie gewinnt an der Macht
wir erwarten zunächst eine
Normalisierung das heißt ja auch eine
restaurative justizprozess für die
großen Schaden in Netz die letzten Jahre
jetzt sitzen
10.000 Menschen in Gefängnissen
ungerecht Wein diese AGP Mehrheit der
Koalition die Justiz als Apparat für die
Unterdrückung der
Opposition sehr stark
zurück im Erdbebengebiet in der Stadt
passarchic Familie Charity hat mich zu
sich nach Hause eingeladen
direkt nach dem Erdbeben mussten auch
sie im Zelt Leben drei Tage lang hatten
sie nichts zu essen
gab es denn schnell Unterstützung von
der Regierung oder wo kam das Zelt her
das Zelt ist von uns
wir haben es nicht vom Staat bekommen es
gehört uns
die anderen hier sind vom Staat
nach drei Tagen kam die Hilfe sie
brachten Brot wir haben es geteilt damit
alle versorgt waren so haben wir
gefrühstückt und das alles im Stehen es
regnete und schneite es gab keine
Möglichkeit zu sitzen alles war nass
danach haben wir das Zelt aufgebaut am
Anfang haben wir mit 15 Personen darin
gewohnt das dauerte mehrere Wochen es
war sehr eng für alle
erst seit wenigen Tagen trauen sie sich
wieder zurück ins Haus seit der
Katastrophenschutz ist trotz Schäden für
sicher genug erklärt hat
die Familie genießt das endlich wieder
im Haus zu leben und zu kochen
der Regierung machen Sie hier zu meiner
Überraschung keine Vorwürfe
glauben Sie denn dass diese mangelnde
Hilfe sich bei den Wahlen auswirkt mein
Wahlverhalten wird es nicht beeinflussen
es war nicht nur eine Provinz betroffen
sondern 11 gleichzeitig auch der Staat
wusste nicht was er tun soll
die Schuld an der Katastrophe gibt die
Schwiegertochter vor allem gierigen
Bauunternehmen und lokalen Behörden
Schuld sehe ich zum Beispiel darin dass
für bestimmte Gebäude eine Bauerlaubnis
erteilt wurde obwohl die Vorschriften
nicht erfüllt waren
viele Menschen sind wegen der Fehler der
Bauunternehmer gestorben
zwar gilt die Baubranche in der Türkei
tatsächlich als korrupt doch für die
Regierung halten die Bauunternehmer auch
als Sündenböcke hier und von mangelnder
staatlicher Kontrolle abzulenken
die Familie lädt nicht zum gemeinsamen
Abendessen ein bei Suppe Salat und
türkischer Pizza erzählen Sie mir wie
sehr sie Präsident Erdogan trotz der
Erdbebenkatastrophe bewundern
warum sind sie denn so überzeugt von
Recep Tayyip Erdogan
das hängt damit zusammen dass er alles
erfüllt hat was er versprochen hat
er hat Brücken gebaut
den Flughafen Straßen er kündigte an
bewaffnete und unbewaffnete Drohnen zu
bauen auch das hat er gemacht
sollte Erdogan doch verlieren haben sie
hier düstere Befürchtungen was glauben
Sie was passiert wenn Recep Tayyip
Erdogan verliert die Zustände würden
sich so entwickeln wie in Syrien ein
Bürgerkrieg würde in der Türkei
ausbrechen die Syrer sind hierher
geflüchtet aber das türkische Volk
könnte irgendwo hingehen das Volk würde
sich auch nicht beugen der Leitspruch
wäre Freiheit oder Tod
ihr Land ohne Erdogan für Türken wie
Familie Charity kaum noch vorstellbar
meine Reise durch die Türkei geht zu
Ende ich habe ein Land erlebt das noch
immer unter den Folgen des Erdbebens
leidet und dazu mit einer schweren
Wirtschaftskrise kämpft doch die Wahl
vor der die Türken stehen ist viel
grundlegender es geht um eine
Richtungsentscheidung die die Zukunft
des Landes prägen dürfte eine
Entscheidung zwischen Demokratie und
Autokratie
[Musik]